RTX.
Nvidia marketed RTX back in 2018 when
they and changed their entire name of
their graphics cards to RTX instead of
GTX. So, Touring is built for RTX. It
was a pretty revolutionary thing because
Nvidia was claiming, hey, ray tracing is
the future. This is where we came from.
You got to be proud of it. You got to
own it. Before, after.
before RTX.
After RTX,
let's go ahead and check out RTX. All
right, I'm in Cyberpunk here. One of the
games that most uses ray tracing to like
benefit where people actually talk about
is like, "Oh, this is a good thing.
What the hell was that?" It doesn't mean
it's a perfect game. Right now, we're
not using any rate tracing in Cyberpunk.
All right, I just want to show you a
little demonstration. As you see in the
top left corner of the screen, I was
running around for a bit. So, this is
fully loaded. We're at about 6.3 GB of
used video memory. Yeah, the game looks
pretty good even without ray tracing.
But let's go ahead and just turn on ray
tracing. Just a simple form of ray
tracing like ray traced reflections. And
you're going to see that VRAMm
consumption jump up. We almost jumped up
by 2 GB of VRAM. And also our FPS got
cut like almost in half just by turning
on ray trace reflections. I think this
deserves another video coming up soon to
see if ray tracing is really worth it.
But now we get reflections on the
ground. But this isn't the highest form
of ray tracing you can get in this game.
So yes, we can up it again. Let's turn
on things like sun shadows, local
shadows, and ray trace lighting up to
ultra. First off, our FPS is going to
drop like crazy, but also our VRAMm
consumption is going to continue to
rise. So remember, we started at like
6.3 GB of VRAM used, and now we're up to
9.3. We've gone up 3 GB of VRAM. our FPS
is in an unusable territory at this
point. What if you have graphics cards
that don't have enough VRAM? Because
right now I'm on the 560 Ti, which does
have an 8 GB version of this graphics
card, but I'm currently on the 16 GB
one, which costs quite a bit of money.
So, let's take a step back into reality.
What graphics cards are most people
actually buying? Jumping over to the
Steam hardware survey, the top graphics
card in the world right now, according
to Steam is RTX 3060. The only graphics
card here that has more than 8 gigabytes
of VRAM in this top part of the charts,
you know, maybe minus the 4070 is a
3060. This card has 12 GB of VRAM, or it
could. There's actually a 3060 that only
has 8 GB of VRAM. So, most of the most
popular graphics cards in the world only
have 8 GB. And as we saw, rate tracing
can use quite a bit more than 8 GB of
VRAM. pretty easily. So, the RTX 560 did
just come out and I made a whole video
about it. If you look at the prices of
this graphics card, yes, it is entry
level. It is going for $300. You can buy
this graphics card for MSRP at $300.
This is like something that's unheard
of. We didn't think you could buy
graphics cards at MSRP, but it has that
crucial crucial downside of being an 8
GBTE card, which means it's going to
struggle with ray tracing in so many
games. It's stupid. Man, Nvidia might
argue that RTX stands for having tensor
cores in it, which is the AI cores. We
love a gamers love AI, I swear. But it's
not because we don't love GeForce. 800
balls on the bottom. 800
balls. Seriously, this 8 GB 5060 very
malnourished and undere equipped if it
wants to actually use RTX. RTX.
And this doesn't change a whole lot as
you go up. Now, Nvidia also offers a
5060 Ti. Now, the 5060 Ti has two
versions, an 8 GB and a 16 GB one. This
one is going for $380. This is going for
MSRP now, which is pretty cool. At least
some things feel like they're healing.
But this is also 8 GB. So, Nvidia's
first two graphics cards are offering
with the 50 series only have 8 GB of
VRAM. So, you have to jump all the way
up to the 5060 Ti 16 GB to get $430.
There's one available at MSRP. A lot of
other ones are 480 because this card has
16 GB of VRAM. So, this is where it
enters another company, AMD. Now, AMD
has seen this opportunity and they've
been like, "Oh, we can provide more VRAM
at the same price points, which will
make our graphics cards maybe better
equipped." Now, let's look at the RX960
XT. Now, this guy is 16 GB of VRAM, and
it's going for $350. if you can buy it
at that price price point, they are sold
out probably because of how popular they
are or because AMD can't keep them in
stock. Like they don't they can't make
enough of them or something. They're
cheaper than the 5060 Ti 16 GB, but
they're not super cheap. AMD is also
offering an 8 GB graphics card here that
is still going for $300. It's MSRP
price. That's for another time to talk
about. Don't think this card is safe.
So, you never think this day would come
that AMD is better at RTX than RTX cards
are. I know it's not actually called
RTX. The Nvidia brainwash here making
RTX in my brain against the 5060. We're
just looking at Assassin's Creed
Shadows. I know everybody's favorite
game at 1080p. This is using the
rateracing everywhere setting in the
game. So, this is rateracing. It's 27%
faster on the 960 XT. Yeah, AMD has made
improvements to rate tracing on the 960
XT and RDNA4, the architecture this is
based on. That immediately leads it to
be quite a bit faster, at least in this
title, even though I don't think the
5060 is super limited by VRAM. Here we
hop over to Cyberpunk 2077 at 1080p. You
know, we just turned on rate trace
reflections a second ago and checked
that out. Well, the 960 XT is 59% faster
than the 5060 if you just turn on ray
trace reflections. That's 100% faster on
the 1% lows as well. Now, these numbers
as you see on the right side are the 1%
lows. Basically, represent how much is
the graphics card stuttering. So, these
are the bottom the average percentage of
the frame rates, the dips that are in
the game. That's because of extra VRAM.
When you hit VRAM limitations, a lot of
the time you end up getting stutters as
the system's trying to load the data
into the GPU. Also to mention, the 960
XT is getting about 60 FPS. And I think
that's a huge thing. like you could
actually play on these settings on the
960 XT. The 5060, despite it being RTX,
you can't do this. Now, if you were to
turn on some upscaling, the 960 XT is
still 64% faster than the 5060 and 129%
faster on the 1% lows. It's getting like
90 FPS. It's getting over 90 FPS. And
the 5060 is still stuck below 60 on its
average. So, not really a great
experience on the 5060 despite rendering
the game at like 720p and upscaling it
to 1080p. And this also means because of
the extra VRAM on the 960 XT, 210%
faster at 1440p with some upscaling. I
mean, that's a huge difference. If you
look over at the 5060, it looks kind of
crazy. It's stuttering all over the
place. And I think it's having these
issues because of DLSS4, the Transformer
model. This version of it does use a
higher quality model for the AI
upscaling, which does mean, at least
what from what I've experienced, it
needs to have more memory on the chip
allocated to it when upscaling usually
alleviates some of the VRAM problems.
Now, if you use the older model of DLSS,
it performs a little bit better, but the
96 XT with way more VRAM does handle the
situation still so much better. Now, if
we want to move on to RA tracing
overdrive, this is path tracing in
Cyberpunk. I wouldn't even attempt this
on the 5060. It is just oh man, it is
bad. But the 9060 is cruising. It's not
like playable. It's still just a little
over 30 fps. But at least you can run
this on the 960 XT. And this is using
upscaling at 1080p. We head over to
Plague Tail Reququum at 1080p with just
ray trace shadows on in the games. Not
much ray tracing. The 960 XT despite it
being AMD and Nvidia made this damn
feature pretty much to run in real-time
ray tracing. It's 17% faster on the AMD
card. I don't think the 5060, at least
in the length of this test, it's pretty
short, isn't really running out of VRAM.
Let's hop over to Ratchet and Clank Rift
Apart. We're at 1080p, which is
rateracing high. It is 74% faster on the
960 XT. It is running laps around this
[__] And the same type of experience
can go up to 1440p. If you use a little
bit of upscaling, you see the 960 XT is
still getting 74 average FPS. That's
147% faster. that card is struggling in
this game. The same type of thing
happens in Spider-Man Miles Morales. I I
just have to show you this game play so
you see what the difference is. This is
what happens when you have an 8 GB
graphics card. One of the only things
that Nvidia actually offers with their
entry-level cards this time around. In
Doom: The Dark Ages as well, this game
uses rate tracing all the time. The 960
XT is still ahead and it's playing
pretty comfortably if you want to play
at 1440p with upscaling. The 560 doesn't
seem to have a VRAM problem, at least in
this case. Now, I got to throw a bone
over to the 560 in Blacksmith Wukong.
Now, this game isn't very VRAM heavy, so
you don't run into those type of issues.
Now, this is usually a very Nvidia
favored title, you know, even with
upscaling at 1080p. The 960 XT is 38%
slower on average and 33% slower in the
1% lows, but it's still only getting 42
average FPS on the 5060. So, I wouldn't
really call this like playable. and
we're already upscaling at 1080p. So, I
don't think the 5060 will ever get you
there, but it's interesting to see where
it can win. And in Allen Wake 2 at 1080p
with upscaling, so we're rendering at
like 720p and upscaling to 1080p. They
actually are about even with the rate
tracing in this title, but neither of
them are really getting above 30 FPS.
So, you're not really going to be
playing on this whatsoever. So Nvidia's
entrylevel RTX graphics card can't
really do RTX because on average, if we
just want to take all these at 1080p
rate tracing, all the tests I did was
rate tracing, the 960 XT is 42% faster
on average. If you want to include the
1% lows because of the reduced VRAM on
the 5060, that means the 960 XT is 71%
faster in the 1% lows. It is stuttering
a lot less. We hop up to 1440p. Not that
you would ever really be rate tracing on
either of these cards at 1440p to be
honest, but the 960 XT is 64% faster on
average, 98% faster in the 1% lows. Now,
I do want to mention something when it
comes down to VRAMm consumption on these
graphics cards. This is something that
Hardware Unbox recently just made a
video on which I think is super super
useful and it is this here and they
talked about Radeon RX96 XT with PCIe
3.0, 4.0, and 5.0. So PCI Express is the
damn slot that you plug the graphics
card into on your system. As you go
older with your different motherboards
and CPUs and stuff, sometimes they can
only support certain levels of PCIe. The
newest one can support like 5.0. There's
a 4.0, there's 3.0. As you see, this is
just an example with the 96 XT 8 GB. On
Gen 5, it's getting like 53 FPS. On Gen
4, it's getting like 45 FPS. On Gen 3,
it's getting like 32 FPS. If you compare
it on the right side here, on Gen 3, the
slowest PCIe mode, the 16 gigabyte 9060
XT is getting 68 FPS. So, more than all
of these. All right? And that's because
as you run out of VRAM on your system,
your graphics card offloads that memory
that it needs. It offloads that to your
system memory. As you'll see in a lot of
these tests, the 5060, if you look at
the memory on the system, so as you see
my CPU and then the memory right below
it for RAM, it's going to be higher
consumption on the 560 when it's running
out of VRAM because it's offloading some
of that to the system memory. Now, this
ends up having limitations when it comes
up to the PCIe bandwidth. It needs to
transport that data to the RAM on your
system. Seems like the 560 stutters
quite a damn bit. And that's because I'm
only using PCIe Gen 4 on this system.
Now, this is just how I test. That's
because my riser cable doesn't run Gen
5. My motherboard actually does support
PCIe Gen 5, but I don't typically use
it. Honestly, I think this a pretty
typical usage scenario for a lot of
people. So, it really sucks about the
5060. You would want to upgrade like an
older system to have a newer graphics
card in it. This is like a budget
graphics card. You might not upgrade
everything at the same time. And this
card only has 8 GB of VRAM, which
severely limits it. Turns out anything
with this, and I've done testing on this
as well with some other graphics cards
like the 4060 Ti and such, is the 5060
only has a x8 configuration on PCIe,
which means if you have an older system
as well, then it's only going to use
half the bandwidth of the 9060 XT. The
960 XT has a x6 or interface for the
PCIe. So, it can use a lot more
bandwidth even on the slower versions of
PCIe. So the 5060 when it runs out of
VRAM, it's going to be hit extremely
hard, especially if you're on older
systems. And that's just like an
instance of Nvidia cheaping out on the
VRAM and Nvidia cheaping out on the PCIe
bandwidth. There's just nothing
redeemable here. Now, these are budget
graphics cards. And you might want to
say like, oh, you wouldn't expect to do
RA tracing on these cards, but you might
want toinging try it. I mean, you bought
a new graphics card. Do you want to try
rateracing? Now, in terms of this price
to performance on the 5060 versus the
960 XT, if you look in rasterized
performance, which I honestly think that
most people that are getting these
graphics cards are going to be looking
more at raster instead of rateracing.
So, honestly, in terms of the
performance, the 960 XT, even raster,
not just rate tracing, presenting pretty
damn significant performance uplifts
over the RTX 5060 in a lot of these
games. That's one part uh due to the
extra VRAM. Now, the 960 XT is still
more expensive by a good amount, but
still at this price point is more
competing to Nvidia's RTX 560 Ti 8 GB.
These are more the exact same price and
this card has 8 GB of VRAM. So, despite
the 5060 Ti being more expensive, it's
going to struggle just as much in terms
of rate tracing. Now, I don't have the 8
GB 5060 Ti to exactly show you that, but
it has tons of issues. You'll see some
stuff from like Daniel Owen, see some
stuff from Hardware Unbox with their
side by sides. How many issues that this
card runs into? This is the 960 XT 16 GB
review. And here is the 560 Ti 8 GB. You
see it's only getting 62fps
compared to the 960 XT. Now, this is not
rateracing. It's at 1440p which does use
more VRAM. There's a 70 there's 8 FPS
difference here in the 5060 Ti. Here is
the 16 GB card. And then here is the 8
GB card. So despite these having the
exact same GPU die, they are much much
further apart. They perform so much
different, especially when it comes to
things like ray tracing or going up in
resolution in many many different games
or increasing texture detail, that type
of stuff. Nvidia is offering these 8 GB
graphics cards that really can't do that
much rate tracing. When you even compare
it, the 5060 to the ARK B580. This is
Intel's graphics card, but this is a 12
GB graphics card for $250. So $50 less
than the 5060. Rate tracing is a lot
closer than you might think. Even on
average, these cards average out because
of how inconsistent the 5060 is when it
comes from title to title because of the
limited VRAM. What I think is hilarious
though is how Nvidia advertises these
graphics cards. Yes, they advertise the
RTX 5060 for example on rateracing. So
here is Nvidia's website. This is their
own data. Yes, there's all of these
points on the left side here which use
multi-frame generation. I hate going
over this every time cuz it's so
misleading. Here is Resident Evil 4.
This is the only data that they show for
the RTX 5060. The only data they show
has ray tracing on it. They're marketing
this card with either using multi-frame
generation which uses more VRAM as well.
There's many issues with 5060 and
multi-frame generation. You'll actually
see sometimes that the 5060 performs
worse when enabling frame generation
because frame generation uses more VRAM
on the 5060 Ti. It shows in the fine
print here that they're testing the 16
GB versions of the 5060 Ti and the 4060
Ti. Obviously putting the 5060 Ti in its
best light and they're also only
advertising this card using RA tracing.
So, to me, this kind of stuff feels damn
near just like false advertising is like
you're not really going to use ray
tracing on the 5060. Really, you're not
going to use ray tracing until the 5060
Ti 16 GB because it's not really
available at the $430 MSRP, which maybe
it will come down eventually here. It
seems like they're starting to work
their way down, but it's regularly more
available at $480. So, this card is
expensive. You can't even start to
really use Nvidia's features unless you
pay this much on one of their new
graphics cards. What I find really
interesting, too, this holds up so much
better. If Nvidia gives their graphics
cards more VRAM, then it competes way
more closely with the 960 XT because at
1080p with rate tracing, I found the
5060 Ti is about 25% faster than 960 XT.
These are both the 16 GB versions of
these graphics cards. If we jump up to
1440p where more VRAM is used. Also, the
5060Ti has faster VRAM but quite a bit
faster. 31% faster on average. Now, I
will say that even at 1440p, the 5060Ti
on average is only getting about 35 FPS
though. So, you're not really going to
be rate tracing at native 1440p. Maybe
in some more titles you could use some
upscaling to get away with it a bit
more. It shows in a lot of titles the
5060Ti 16 gigabyte is a good bit faster
in terms of rate tracing is where you
would expect these cards to line up.
It's not like the 9060 XT holds up
poorly. AMD is competing relatively
well, but you're paying quite a bit more
for the Nvidia graphics card. So, I
think it makes sense here. So, this
makes me think of the 5060, the base
5060 at $300. If this card had more than
8 GB of VRAM, it would probably stack up
a lot better against the 9060 XT, which
I just think is insane. Nvidia
advertises this feature and then not a
lot of their cards can even leverage the
feature. And it gets worse as you go up
the pricing stack for Nvidia, at least
in my opinion, because Nvidia also
offers the RTX 5070 RT and Resident Evil
4 just like the other ones, but they
offer Horizon Forbidden West with DLSS.
There's only one title here that doesn't
use ray tracing or some kind of
multi-frame generation [__] And how
does that card hold up in terms of
rateracing performance? Well, not that
great because we see hard on boxes data
here versus the 9070 XT. This is AMD's
$600 graphics card, which honestly would
you think AMD's card would beat Nvidia's
graphics card in terms of rate tracing
performance? These are about neck
andneck. The 5070 and the 9070 XT
because the 97 XT has more VRAM and AMD
did make improvements in terms of their
rate tracing on this card. And this also
shows that the 9070 59 FPS here honestly
relatively close to the 5070. And why
does the 5070 have so many issues? Well,
because the 5070 only has 12 gigabytes
of VRAM. Despite it being $550, it
actually has less VRAM than the 560Ti,
at least the 16 GB version. You can see
this being an issue in some specific
titles like Daniel Owen here is showing
rateracing ultra in Cyberpunk, which
uses quite a bit of VRAM. And this guy
is on performance upscaling. The 9070
from AMD is beating the 5070 from
Nvidia. The 9070 XT is beating it by
22%.
All in the same price range here. That's
because you see at the top of the
screen, it is getting pretty close in
terms of its memory performance. As you
see, the 9070 is using almost 10 GB of
VRAM and it's allocating over 12 GB. The
9070 XT is relatively in that range as
well. So, even up to $550,
the 5070 is still malnourished in terms
of VRAM. It should be able to get a
better performance than it is. Now, I've
seen this in my own testing with the
4070 Super. In terms of performance, the
4070 Super is really damn close to the
5070. You compare it to the 9070 XT. You
can see the VRAM limitations on the 4070
Super become issues. These cards are
anemic, but you're really looking at a
TI.
These guys are like $840 and they're the
first Nvidia graphics card with enough
RA tracing performance. Like the 560Ti
16 GB has enough VRAM but not enough
performance. But the 5070Ti has 16 GB
and it has enough rate tracing
performance to maybe actually start
using it in some goddamn video games.
And then this card is $840.
You could buy two 960 XT 16 GB for the
price of 1570 Ti just to get the
rateracing features, the RTX that is
really advertised on the damn name of
the graphics card. Nvidia is offering
these cards that can't really do any
rate tracing. They neither don't have
the performance or they don't have the
VRAM capacity. And AMD is in a position
where they can get better rate tracing
performance than Nvidia. It's a crazy
situation and they did offer that. The
problem is AMD and I'm going to make a
follow-up video on this cuz it is just
ridiculous. But AMD has to go and spoil
the whole situation by making an 8 GB
version of the 960 XT, poisoning the
well. like the 96 TXT 16 gigabyte is
better at rate tracing, has FSR4, is at
a competitive price point of an MSRP of
$350, which as we see has been sold out.
So obviously people are interested in
this graphics card. If I look on
MicroEnter right now, here's a 960 XT.
If you scroll down, there's a lot of the
8 GB versions of these graphics cards,
but if you scroll down a bit and you can
start to find some of the 16 GB ones,
there actually is one available at MSRP
of $350. It's only two in stock, at
least at the microenter I go to. You
could get this card at $350. And at $350
is honestly a really good deal. But this
card goes ahead and has to just spoil
and ruin everything. This is like this
was supposed to be a happy day, but
basically AMD had to go and ruin the
whole thing. AMD just needs to shut up.
Their freaking executives have to go on
Twitter and cope that 1080p everybody
just plays at 1080p and nobody plays
games that run with over 8 GB of Vero.
Even though we saw so many regular
examples 960 XT running so much better
than like a 5060 or something like that
because of the VRAM capacity on the
graphics card. This is such a stupid
thing. I actually found it really funny
that Grock here, the AI on Twitter made
a pretty amazing summary of this
situation. Grock is kind of based. Now,
I do want to mention too because this is
sort of a 960 XT review, the 16 GB
graphics card mostly to be honest, but I
did want to compare it to the 7600 XT,
which would technically be this graphics
card's last gen counterpart. It's pretty
impressive to see what the 960 XT has
done here, what AMD has done here.
Rasterized performance. If we just look
at 1080p, the 960 XT is about 39% faster
on average in so many titles. And at
1440p, it's 43% faster on average.
That's a lot because the 7600 XT was
$330 last generation with RDNA3. 960 XT
at MSRP is technically $350. So $20
increase, but you're getting like like
40% more performance. I mean, that's
pretty insane. Both of these cards do
have 16 GB of VRAM. And if we look at
the rate tracing performance, on
average, I found the 960 XT to literally
be twice as fast as the 7600 XT. You
would pretty much never rate trace on
the 7600 XT. That'd be pretty stupid.
You wouldn't really rate trace that much
on the 960 XT either, but twice as fast
is pretty insane for a generation of
graphics cards. Now, what's interesting
as well is against AMD's last generation
7700 XT because this is kind of closer
in line to the 9660 in terms of price.
7700 XT did go as low as $380 last
generation before, but it did
technically start at 450 and then
dropped like around 400 for a lot of its
life. Now, the 960 XT 16 GB is actually
about the same rasterized performance as
the 7700 XT, at least in a lot of the
tests that I did. Now, the 7700 XT only
has 12 GB of RAM, whereas you're getting
four more GB on the 60 XT here. But in
terms of the rate tracing performance,
that's where we see a lot of these
things shine. At 1080p, the 960 XT is
like 35% faster. This isn't using
upscaling or anything like that. So, you
could probably use upscaling, get
playable performance on the 960 XT. Now,
the power consumption is pretty
impressive as well. So, as you see in
Kingdom Come Deliverance 2, it's getting
a little bit of a higher frame rate. And
then you look up at the top and the 7700
XT has drawn over 200 watts close to
like 215 210 a lot of the time. The 960
XT is hovering around like 175 watts. So
this isn't rasterized performance. When
we hop over to rate tracing in Allen
Wake 2 with quality upscaling at 1080p
rate tracing medium. So this is pretty
heavy rate tracing in the game. You see
that the 7700 XT draws even more power
than it did in just a raster game. now
it's like over 220 watts a lot of the
time whereas the 960 XT is more like 175
still. So a lot more power efficient
especially when it comes to rate
tracing. Now if you want to stack this
up against AMD's RDNA4 graphics cards
here. So the 9070 XT generally is
speaking on the market right now. The
970 XT is over twice as much as the 9060
XT 16 GB. What's interesting is both
these cards have 16 GB of VRAM. The 970
XT has like twice the memory bandwidth
because the 960 XT is basically half of
a 9070 XT. Like straight up in like
every metric, the bus width, the GPU die
size, all that kind of stuff. And in
terms of raster drives performance
though, that doesn't mean it gets half
the performance at 1440p. I found the
9070 XT on average to be about 68%
faster. It It isn't half the performance
on the 960 XT. If you jump up to 4K, it
is 82% faster on the 970 XT. That
probably is because of the increased
memory bandwidth. And the 970 XT has a
pretty large lead in terms of the rate
tracing performance. Maybe making ray
tracing a little bit more usable of a
feature, especially with some upscaling
at 1440p or something like that. I
wouldn't really recommend it on the 960
XT. So, pretty damn interesting. And if
you want to know my my thoughts on the
card itself, this 960 XT 16 GB was sent
to me by AMD, which I think is kind of
funny because they didn't send the 8 GB
one. I know. Crazy thing. I even asked
them to send an 8 GB card, but they knew
they knew it was going to get reviewed
poorly by so many people, so they just
said, "Hey, we're not going to do that."
They're doing the same [__] as Nvidia
does. Now, this card itself, this is the
Asus Prime model. I have the Asus Prime
model of the 5070 Ti as well. This card
runs pretty well, I would say. I mean,
the temperature is under control. I
flipped the BIOS switch on the card as
well, and it doesn't really perform any
different on either BIOS, so I wouldn't
really like consider that at all. But,
it is three fans. What I think is funny
is it is an absolutely massive graphics
card, but it only has two heat pipes in
it. But the back plate is metal and
there's also pads on the back of it
because the memory is clamshelled. So
there's memory on the front by the GPU
die. There's also memory on the back.
The card I think is pretty nice and this
apparently is supposed to be an MSRP I
think 96 TXT. This is a crazy situation
where here in 2025 we see you think
almost every time so far with ray
tracing history that Nvidia cards were
on top. Not necessarily if Nvidia makes
their cards so anemic that it can't even
use this damn feature that they
advertise on their cards. And this
really goes all the way up into the RTX
5070 with 12 GB of VRAM. So yeah, the
960 XT 16 GB is pretty damn good. If you
can get it for $350, I recommend it.
It's going to get a lot of things done.
AMD still needs to work on some things.
This will be an upcoming video. So let
me know what you think about the 960 XT
16 GB. Would you buy an AMD card for RTX
or would you buy an RTX card for RTX? I
mean, like, you would think it wouldn't
be a decision, but that's the situation
we're in where Nvidia is intentionally
hamstringing their graphics cards to
make you want to spend more and more and
more if you want to actually use the
features they advertise on the damn box
or what they put in the damn name of the
graphics card. I know. Crazy thing. Let
me know what you think and I'm going to
see you in the next one. All right,
peace.